l'hack è male o freri schiacciare il
tasto di registrazione troppo forte mi
sono staccato un dito
spiego adesso vi faccio questa lezione
lezione dimostrativa come faccio io a
sincronizzare la mia webcam con il
gameplay semplicemente quando faccio
partire la registrazione del gameplay in
montaggio so che ho fatto per della
registrazione perché faccio una sorta di
chuck come funzionano i film però che
ciò che faccio io siccome c'è un tasto
per registrare riempe lei che sulla mia
tastiera f9 schiaccio quel tasto forte
in modo tale che nel montaggio sento
quando schiacciato il tasto e m gameplay
lo schiaccio tipo così tutti i miei
gameplay iniziano che io schiaccio
fortissimo un tasto della tastiera si
vede c'è e si vede
mi sono fatto malissimo e oggi siamo su
boxing surgery simulator calza a
pennello rai mi sono fatto male
ve la spiego avete presente cos'è la
boxe la boxe è quello sport che ti
picchi forte ecco quello la boxe è fatta
di round ogni volta che un round finisce
il pugile viene medicato dal suo team di
medici ok io sono quel team di medici
quindi mi richiamo iboxx satori che si
fanno male le di gary non lei schierino
battle for the bar bill la battaglia ed
as indexpoint verba perché c'è un rasoio
in mano vabbè adesso c'è un caso o parka
la cavai come si chiama il loro
picchiare pure ai non avevo capito
episodio da solo medicare bravura se non
dopo in sta andando benissimo a carico
ti vogliono mettiamo subito un cerotto
qua no
mettiti cuciamo prima qui no col filo
neanche un po toni cotone cotone vai
picchia picchia forte vai spaccati a fa
lo so che ce la fai mamma mia
guardali madonna che poi diventare blu
adesso per diventare viola ci penso io
dente un dente nuovo togliamo prima
quello che c'è lì come si trovi con
questo togliamo il dente togliamo le non
togliamo il dente il cerotto
nell'orecchio neanche quello
muori ok sin il fatale è morto per
attacco di cuore
non sono stato io vorrei ragazzi non
capisco come ho fatto a perdere che
strano vabbè riproviamoci picchiato
picchia picchia cioè le tue cose picchia
più forte di prima
picchia picchia a ma io posso cliccar e
le frasi se vuol dire ok se sei nuovo
sei non ti sei fatto niente islate
niente lo togliamo sullo status ora che
schifo non vogliamo più ma io quindi
posso schiacciare sulle cose lo
schiacciano capito cosa devo fare però
vabbè con la colla è cerotto no
i denti sono a posto cotone cotone che
puliamo no questo per togliere le cose
porca eva non so medicare la sono far
faccio schifo oa fra nerone che sei
majin bu e cioè nel senso che sta
succedendo lì allora cosa vuol fare qua
il cerotto avere le pustole coi cerotti
mi sembra chiaro ovviamente lo schiaccia
e sulle cose positive e non avevo capito
vai di cerotti ma di cerotti cerotti
sulle pustole gelato sulle ferite
sull'occhio gelato sull'occhio
sull'altro occhio no kill the advantages
da ied the way we die e va bene porca
vacca è difficilissimo perché non cala
ma scusate che come faccia come si
curano le persone perché non ho capito
allora colla no cerotto no collana la
verità no dente la ferita rasoio e una
ferita cotone la ferita non la puoi
curare ha così
ma dai ma è molto pianistico di quanto
pensassi
rifacciamo aspettati cuccio io ti faccio
io non avevo capito si cuce così
perfetto o amen aspetta che la busta è
un casino
come si fa a ho capito come si fanno
certe robe a il gelato per le pustole
grandi chiarissimo questo è un gioco non
guardate questi video mentre mangiate
per cortesia alla gelata sulla pustola
eccola chiarissimo c'è una stella lì la
stella alla stella con la colla ho
capito come si curano le persone è che
bellissimo sto gioco non avevo capito
prima dai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai sicuro io ci penso io
l'orecchio sanguigna non so che fare
devo cucire con l'orecchio cosa facevi
cotone e l'orecchio era cotone porca
vacca c'è il cotone ogni cosa al suo la
sua cura molto chiaro ok quindi il
cotone o in st ridotto dio mio ok
l'occhio cosa faccio gol occhi ma i
denti
ok a posso metterti denti buoni va bene
chiaro la colla non chiedete perché la
colla dovrebbe mettere a posto tipo le
stelle prove sono morto tre record 6
round fatto due round 4 round sei round
manca l'ottavo se vogliamo fare al
tabellina del 2
proviamoci adesso ho capito come si cura
non è male ci ho messo una vita però fai
bene stai bene stai bene chi sa come
fanno la preferite che stai usando dei
guanti la boxe com'è possibile avere un
faccia domande vai vai vai spacca di
luppi spacca lo spacco sui colli di
cartoni in bocca morale nadia curati
curati by spacca gli spacca lì ma la
colla cosa serve a queste soste alle
stelle perché quando è stordito tipo i
pokémon nuovo capitolo scusava piegherà
la fir spacca lo spacca lo spacca lo
magari a tutti i denti di sopra tutta
l'arcata di sopra da rifare vai vai
perfetto c 6 c 6 ce l'hai 6 carico ti
vedo che sei carico pensa che è un
hayter un'iter spacca i commenti
positivi lo tirano il sud se non so
perché nokia andato o che sta diventando
complicata la faccenda raffreddati all
occhio andato come si cura con il gela
no no il rasoio
che schifo apostoli ho aperto l'occhio
non fate domande non sono medico io cura
basta vai vai picchia picchia che non
siamo round 6 record che sta veramente
difficile superare il 6 come round è
veramente un casino
nokia male la colla vai minchia quante
ferite cia sto tizio ba vang all around
7 raga record però non so se lo supero
ci provo looking un porco demonio vale
emily la pantera
non mi sembrava per niente emili quella
dei ragazzi abbiamo dato con la medicina
sul ring vediamo di riuscire a fare un
po di indicazioni in ospedale visto che
me la cavo così bene sul ring oggi ho
deciso di fare un trapianto di pope
siamo su non mi so se vi ricordate il
saggio di squat è bellissimo non vedo la
libertà del trapianto di seno come me la
cavo
sono convinto liri cioè ma quelle da
sabri gamer ancora meglio
ciao zia andati sì perché a te lo devo
fà ciao dottor susy ora ma do questo
fatto ha pianto di fascia però prima del
black star tranquillo faccio io che sono
capannoni di spiegarlo so.ha devo
disegnare proprio ok qui lo metto qua
ciao tette a posto
faccio io faccio molto bene esattamente
così l'avevo fatto per carità amo
dobbiamo farli la flebo orale
l'anestesia cavolo non estesi a fantasia
ha quindi lo addormenti proprio va bene
ma bastavano i video dimette bis e per
far questo non sto scherzando
o forse no tu parla questa phone
trapianto rindi di corde vocali tu per
cortesia che schifo dopo io devo fa ste
cagate ma chi ma ha pagato per fa ma che
schifo ma devo infilare il dito
nell'incisione che bello il lavoro del
medico manovale io faccio youtuber ok
che brutto che lavora otto non mi piace
non sono una donna non mi fa veramente
schifo per tutte le ragazze che stanno
guardando questo video non fan siete
belle lo stesso tipo dio ma no vabbè
oggi video è andato così che vedevo dio
rega provato a fare una roba decente
uscito west c'è pensò di farmi trapianto
un po più easy avendo noi le tele il
silicone proprio tipo come se fosse la
ricotta cioè nel senso che questa una
scatolina della ricotta tu apri e infili
nel fantastico di metter la ricotta ok
faccio io zitta stai zitta che non hai
problemi a parlare faccio io madonna
dovuto metterlo dentro ci metto poco una
cosa molto strana però mi piace fare
avanti e indietro quindi il nostro senso
di farlo veramente ma che schifo ma
basta infilare la roba vasta vasta
secondo le cose ciao sono stato io a
farti stare hai visto che bravo mamma
meno male che si è andato dal dentista
prima non mi interessano e dalle forze
va bene così before and after mamma mia
ragazzi avete bisogno di dette non
problema chiedete a me no chiedete a me
che è meglio ragazzi oggi ho fatto un po
di saint gery spero che vi sia sia il
vostro gradimento il surgery non è di
mio gradimento
forse di costi mio no perché non fai
fatto il medico per questo motivo beh
per tanti altri soprattutto perché se
schiaccia il pulsante della tastiera mi
si fa col dito quindi ecco non c'è altra
pianta di dito da qualche parte però
ragazzi spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto io con quello che l'episodio
come mi piace è sempre bello riprendere
gli attrezzi da medico da sarge un
simulator ai tempi fino adesso non è
cambiato niente sono sempre più bravo ma
mi fa sempre più schifo casi di ragazzi
veloce quando mi piace che adesso
cercando descrizione se non sono così
rischiate vi e noi ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]